ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE ON CLIMATE CRISIS
RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION A WE ARE GOING
TO BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
SINCE WERE SHOT BY A COUPLE OF-
MEMBERS TO- CREATE A QUORUM-
BUT- WE WILL ALSO SEND SERVER
ONLY CALENDAR IS GOING TO BE
ONE OR MAYBE- A SMALL NUMBER
OF- OF VOTES WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO WAIT FOR A QUORUM TO- TO
PROCEED WITH THOSE. AND SO I
THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS SET MOVE
FORWARD IN THE CALENDAR TO
ITEMS TO BE HEARD AND- WE HAVE
PRESENTATIONS ON ISSUES ONE TWO
AND THREE IF WEEK- OUR
PRESENTERS READY TO PROCEED
WITH THOSE NOW. I'M GETTING THE
NOD YES AND SO WHY DON'T WE
PROCEED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
CALTRANS ISSUE ONE WHICH IS-
CARE ACT TO AT G. E. T. F. S.
IN SUPPORT. THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER. I TRIED TO **** THE
LONGEST POSSIBLE. THE
REPRESENTATIVE. YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW WHAT I HAVE TO ASK YOU TO
PAUSE PLEASE I'M NOT I'M NOT
FALL SORRY ABOUT THAT- I'M NOT
FOLLOWING SCRIPT PROPERLY HERE-
SO LET ME DO OUR NORMAL
INTRODUCTION I MUST HAVE
THOUGHT THAT I WAS BACK IN PRE
COVERED DAYS AND I DIDN'T HAVE
TO DO A PREAMBLE TO THE
MEETINGS- BUT WE ARE IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN TODAY HAVING
A PHYSICALLY DISTANT. IN PERSON
HEARING. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE IN THIS ROOM A FEW
MEMBERS A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF
STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC. AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
KEEP SIX FEET OF SPACING. THERE
ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
HERE TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I'LL RESTATE THIS WHEN
THE PUBLICCOMMENT BEGINS BUT
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE RUM WISHES TO SPEAK. THEY
WILL RAISE THEIR HANDS AND I
WILL ASK THEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC RESPECT FOR THE CALL
DISTANCING. AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU'LL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEN PLEASE EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU PUBLIC COMMENT IS
DONNA RETURNING YOUR SEATS. BUT
PLEASE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING ELIMINATING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA AND THE L. A. O. R.
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY WITH RESPECT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING. IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND SHOULD
BE ALSO ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS. PUBLIC TOLL FREE.
877-692-8957 THAT IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN THE ONLY THIS
CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS AT ALL PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE THAT IS. 916-319-2099 A
STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING. PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY. BUT YOU
CAN'T REALLY DO IT BEFORE THE
HEARING HOUSE BUT- WE WILL
STILL ACCEPT YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. OF ADDRESS TO BUDGET
SUB THREE BUDGET SUB THREE.
THAT'S ONE WORD AT A S. M. DOT
CA DOT GOV BUDGET SUB THREE AT
ASM DOT CA DOT GOV. WITH THAT I
THINK WE CAN NOW PROCEED. TO
OUR FIRST ISSUE UNDER ITEMS TO
BE HEARD ISSUE ONE. THANK YOU
FOR PATIENTS. THANK YOU
JEROBOAM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STEVEN
CHECK I'M THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER OF CALTRANS. ON THIS
FIRST ITEM WE'RE REQUESTING TO
UTILIZE SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE NINETY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS RECEIVED AND
RURAL AREA FUNDING UNDER THE
CORONAVIRUS AID RELIEF AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY ACT OR THE
CARE ACT TO SUPPORT MEDIUM
SMALL AND ROLL AGENCIES TO
ACHIEVE CONSISTENT COMPLIANCE
WITH GEN DEFEAT CATIONS ALSO
KNOWN AS G. YEAH S. N.
CONTACTLESS PAYMENT STANDARDS.
THIS PROJECT WILL PROVIDE
BACKEND SERVICES AT THE BENEFIT
THANK HUNDREDS OF SMALL.
TRANSIT AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IF IT'S ARE GOING TO BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH STREAMLINED
PROCESS. SIMPLIFIED REPORTING
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY A ROLLOUT
OF STANDARDIZED SERVICES TRAVEL
PLANNING- PAYMENTS AND
ELIGIBILITY VERIFICATION AND
ELIGIBILITY VERIFICATION IS
REALLY WHEN A TRANSIT AGENCY
NEEDS TO. VERIFY IT H. FOR
EXAMPLE FOR SENIOR DISCOUNT
FARE FOR THOSE KIND OF SERVICES
ARE NOW PROVIDED IN PERSON. BY
LEVERAGING THE BUYING POWER OF
THE STATE INSTEAD OF TWO
HUNDRED OR MORE INDIVIDUAL
SMALL TRANSIT AGENCIES. WERE
ABLE TO LEVERAGES BUYING POWER
AND USED GLOBAL DATA STANDARDS
AND- AFFORDABLE PAYMENT AND-
FOR THE GENERAL TRANSIT FEED
SPECIFICATION SO I JUST
MENTIONED. WHICH WILL ALLOW US
TO PROVIDE A SAFE AND SCALABLE
ALTERNATIVES TO BOTH CASH
PAYMENT- TO THE CURRENT. PAPER
TRYING TO SCHEDULE THAT ARE IN
USE AND ALSO TO IN PERSON
VARIABILITY. BURKE ELIGIBILITY
VERIFICATION. I'M AND REALLY
PLEASE JEFF GFS STANDARD ARE
THE BASIS FOR MOST TRANSIT
AGENCIES HAVE A PRESENCE ON THE
WEB SO WHEN YOU GO ON TO GOOGLE
MAPS AND YOU PLAN A TRIP
WHETHER IT'S IN YOUR CAR OR
YOUR TRANSIT- THEY COULD
PROVIDE YOU WITH ESTIMATES OF
HOW LONG IT'LL TAKE. AND HOW TO
GET THERE AND GDF AT STANDARDS
ARE USED FOR THESE TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION. TO GIVE USERS
THROUGH GOOGLE MAPS OR APPLE
MAPS OR WHATEVER THEY USE- AND
IT'S REALLY AN IMPORTANT PART
IN BRINGING AT BISTRO AGENCIES
INTO. REALLY THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND PROVIDING A BETTER
SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU HOW DO WE HAVE ANY-
COMMONER PRESENTATION FROM-
THE- BERMAN A FINANCE OR THE
ALEJO. BENJAMIN POLLAK FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I WOULD
JUST AGREE WITH THE POINT MADE
BY STEVEN CHECK THAT THESE
RESOURCES ARE ESSENTIAL FOR NOT
ONLY BRINGING RURAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES OUT OF THE IMPACTS
FROM THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO
MODERNIZING THEM TO CATCH UP
WITH THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
TECHNOLOGY. THANK YOU. THE
MORNING CARE I UNITS THROW WITH
THE L. A. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
CONCERNS THAT THE PROPOSAL AT
SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION TO
REQUEST MAKES UP ABOUT 8% OF
THE KERRY FACT FUNDING THE
STATE HAS RECEIVED FOR A
SMALLER AND MORE RURAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES AND WE FIND THAT THE
REQUEST IS REASONABLE GIVEN THE
NEED TO THE TRANSIT AGENCY TO
COLLECT VERY SAFELY DURING THE
PAST THAT MAX. RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE A QUESTIONS
FROM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. I
HAVE NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
AT THIS TIME PERFECT THANK YOU-
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO THEN THE HIGHWAY SAFETY
PROGRAM. MR **** THANK YOU
CHAIR AGAIN FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME IS STEVEN CHECK CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER CALTRANS. IN
THIS ITEM ARE REQUESTING A TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM INCREASE OF
ABOUT TWENTY TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS TO FIND A PILOT
OF THE NEW. HIGHWAY MAINTENANCE
WORKER SAFETY PROGRAM. SO THIS
WOULD BE A TWO YEAR PILOT UNDER
THE EXISTING UMBRELLA A HIGHWAY
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. AND ITS
NEW INITIATIVE WOULD ALLOW US
TO QUICKLY INSTALL AND MAINTAIN
STATE HIGHWAY SAFETY
COUNTERMEASURES WITHIN A YEAR
ADVOCATES. AND WITHOUT THIS
THIS PROGRAM THAT WOULD LIKE
THE PILOT BE SEEKING PLANTS
MINUTES WOULD BE INSTALLED AS
PART OF A LARGER CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS AND- THOSE PROJECTS
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY. OF
THE WORK GETS DONE AND THE SIZE
OF THE PROJECT THEY CAN TAKE
YEARS TO DO. SO BY IMPLEMENTING
THIS PILOT PROGRAM WHERE WE'RE
JUST GOING TO FOCUS ON STALLING
OCD COUNTERMEASURES- WE BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN HAVE A QUICK
HITTING AN IMPORTANT IMPACT.
WITH REALLY TREMENDOUS BENEFITS.
EVERY YEAR. NEAR THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED PEOPLE DIE AND MORE
THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
ARE SERIOUSLY INJURED ON
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. THAT AVERAGES ABOUT TEN
DEATHS A DAY AND THREE OF THOSE
ARE IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
USERS FOLKS WHO. BIKE AND WALK
ON THE HIGHWAY TRANSPORT SORRY
ON THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN
GENERAL. SO WE'D REALLY LIKE
TO- HI THAT THIS PROGRAM THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO IMPLEMENT
THESE QUICK FIXES TO PROVIDE A-
FOCUS ON SAFETY. AND AND MOVE
QUICKLY TO REDUCE THE
FATALITIES AND SERIOUS INJURIES
ON OUR ROADS. THANK YOU I ANY-
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR THE L.
A. L. JAMES MORE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- DISLIKED- CONCUR WITH-
WITH CALTRANS WE CAN CURRENT
THE- REQUEST TO FUND THE
EXPANDED PILOT PROGRAM AND-
WILL CLOSELY MONITOR THE
PROGRAM'S RESULTS OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS TO SEE. IF THE FUTURE
MORE LONG TERM REQUEST IS
WARRANTED. THANK YOU. WARNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN- RECOMMEND AS
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- AND REVIEWING THIS
PROPOSAL WE HAD NO CONCERNS WE
FIND IT REASONABLE TO AUGMENT
THE- MAINTENANCE PROGRAM- TO
SUPPORT THESE CITY PROJECTS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
RISE. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT WE ARE
ON- THE- AND ITEMS TO BE HEARD-
ISSUE NUMBER THREE AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO THE- OF
OUR ONLY CALENDAR WHEN WE HAVE
QUORUM. AND WILL VOTE ON THIS
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM- ISSUE
NUMBER THREE- MISTER KEPT.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE RECORD
STEVEN CHECK WITH THE WITH
CALTRANS. SO THIS ITEM IS OUR
ANNUAL BUDGET ADJUSTMENT FOR
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY SUPPORT
PROGRAM IN THIS CASE WE'RE
REQUESTING AN INCREASE OF ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION AND FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT FULL TIME
EQUIVALENTS. FOR PROJECT
DELIVERY WORKBOOK IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR.
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
INCREASING WORKLOAD TO DELIVER
PROJECTS RELATED TO SENATE BILL
ONE AND WITH OUR ASSET
MANAGEMENT REQUIREMENTS. TOTAL
WORKLOAD RESOURCES THAT ARE
REQUESTED TO ARE SPLIT IN THE
TRADITIONAL 90% STATE STAFF AND
10% ARCHITECTURAL AND
ENGINEERING CONTRACTS. WHAT THE
DELIVERY OR CAPITAL THEY
SUPPORT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT AND OVERSIGHT OF
ALL CAPITAL PROJECTS ON STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM. COS PROGRAM
PROVIDES RESOURCES NECESSARY
FOR PROJECT DESIGN
ENVIRONMENTAL PLANNING RIGHT OF
WAY ACQUISITION. EASEMENTS AND
SALES CONSTRUCTION ENGINEERING
AND CONTRACT MANAGEMENT AND
PORTS PROJECT. IT'S THE LARGEST
PROGRAM IN CALTRANS
REPRESENTING ALMOST HALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT. INFO FIVE. RECORD
GIVE ME THE RESOURCES THAT WE
ARE REQUESTING WILL ALLOW US TO
PRESERVE AND IMPROVE ON THE
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IF NOT TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INVESTED IN THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM. WHICH IS THE FOUNDATION%
OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY ALLOWING
US TO MOVE GOODS AND PEOPLE
EFFICIENTLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
CAPITAL OUTLAYS WERE PROGRAM
WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE ITS
COMMITMENT TO DELIVER PROJECTS.
TO CONSTRUCTION. AND TO OVERSEE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THOSE
PROJECTS THAT ARE ALREADY FULLY
FUNDED EITHER THROUGH THE CTC.
ONCE YOU MEET THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION OR
THROUGH OUR LOCAL PARTNER.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
JAMES MORE WITH- FINANCE WE
CONCUR WITH THIS WORKLOAD
REQUEST- FULLY STAFFED CALTRANS
TO COMPLETE ALL THE REQUIRED
ENGINEERING WORK FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS PLANNED
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LMAO FOR THE COMMENTS.
FRANK MINUTES AGAIN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
THIS REQUEST AND PROPOSAL WAS
RELEASED LAST WEEK'S OUR OFFICE
IS STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
MEETING WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON
THIS ISSUE- HOPE TO HAVE OUR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF- BY NEXT WEEK OR IN THE
COMING WEEKS. THANK YOU AND
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY WE HAVE A
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN- AND- LET'S MOVE
ON NOW TO PUBLIC COMMENT- THE
PUBLIC IS INVITED TO MAKE
COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE ON THE
AGENDA. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK THEY MAY RAISE THEIR HAND
AT ALL ASK THEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WE WANTS TO SPEAK. LOOK LIKE A
WE'RE GONNA TAKE- ROLAND JUST A
SECOND ESTABLISH A QUORUM. ALAS
THAT THE PUBLIC RESPECT FOR THE
CONSISTENT THING AND NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE IN CASE THERE IS
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM- BUT FOR
EVERYONE- WE'RE GONNA LIMIT
PUBLIC COMMENT TWO ONE MINUTE
PER COMMENT. AND THE. WE WILL-
AGAIN- TAKE TELEPHONE COMMENTS.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THAT PHONE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
SIX NINE FIVE EXCUSE ME. I'M
GONNA START OVER AGAIN.
877-692-8957. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS.
1-315-437-1315 FOUR THREE SEVEN
OPERATOR YOU MAY BEGIN THE-
AND- YEAH. YOU CAN- INVITE
ANYONE WHATEVER COMMENTS THEY
HAVE FOR OR AGAINST ANY
INDIVIDUAL NUMBER- AGENDA ITEM
JUST IDENTIFY THE AGENDA ITEM
THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING ON PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND FOR THOSE ON THE
PHONE IF YOU DO HAVE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME TO GET ON THE PHONE
ONE ZERO IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
A LOT OF A FEW MOMENTS OF
MISTER CHAIR NO COMMENTS COMING
IN. ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU WERE
USUALLY MORE POPULAR THAN THAT.
OF WHY DON'T WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. HELLO HERE SENATE.
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON RIVAS
BUT THE. WILL MOVE OUT TO THE
VOTE ONLY ISSUES THESE. THE
FOURTEENTH EIGHTEEN WE'RE GONNA
PULL ITEM EIGHTEEN FROM THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND I'LL ASK
FOR A MOTION ON VOTE ONLY
ISSUES ONE THREE THROUGH EIGHT
TEN THROUGH FOURTEEN. SIXTEEN
AND. 1-721-325-2720 NINE AND.
303-323-5372 FORTY THREE.
462-409-5450 SEVEN.
622-646-6370 SEVEN OUR MOTION
FOR THOSE THAT. SIX I FORGIVE
ME IF I SAID THAT WRONG SIXTY
SEVEN TO SEVENTY SEVEN THANK.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR KEEPING AN
EYE ON THE CIVIL- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND LET'S HAVE
A ROLL CALL WELL BY SENATE.
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON RIVAS.
FIVE THE NEXT MOTION I WOULD
ASK FOR WOULD BE ON THE
FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY ISSUES.
291-519-2020. EIGHT THIRTY SIX
FORTY FOUR FORTY FIVE FIFTY
THROUGH. FIFTY THREE FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY SIX. FIFTY EIGHT THREE
SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY FIVE. OUR
MOTION. SECOND DISCUSSION YES
OKAY ON ITEM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH YES AN ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
AND ITEM FIFTY SIX AND THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS IT SAID
THAT THERE IS A- NO OBJECTIONS
WERE RAISED ON THE PROPOSAL BUT
IF I REMEMBER BACK OF FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH. THERE WAS
SUBSTANTIAL OBJECTION TO THE OF
VOTING PROGRAM. THE DO BELIEVE
THE FEE INCREASE WAS
SUBSTANTIAL I DON'T HAVE
ACTUALLY REMEMBER THE
PERCENTAGE I THINK WAS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND 80% INCREASE. SO
WHAT THOSE ITEMS I JUST WANT TO
BE CLARIFICATIONS NOT OF STAFFS.
RECOMMENDATION THAT THERE WAS
NO OBJECTION BUT I DO BELIEVE
ON THAT DAY THERE WAS A
SUBSTANTIAL UP THOUGHT
OBJECTION TO THOSE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND- WE HAVE A MOTION
BEFORE US UP WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON WE ARE ON THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR- WE'RE ON
OUR SECOND MOTION NOW- IF YOU'D
LIKE I CAN READ THROUGH THE- OF
THE ITEMS AGAIN. THIS IS THE-
MOTION THE- INCLUDES ITEMS TO
NINE FIFTEEN AT CETERA FEAR
FALLING ON THE ACTION ON NUMBER
ONE WAS THAT I HAVE A YES WE'VE
WE'VE ARE WE WILL COME BACK TO
THAT ONE WHEN WE DO ADD ONS.
NEGATIVE YES WE'RE ON THE ONE
THAT OF THE SECOND MOTION.
WHICH INCLUDES. TWO NINE
FIFTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY DO YOU
WANT ME TO READ THE REST OF THE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SAID HAVE A
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE MENTION.
I BELIEVE WE HAD A MACHINE WELL
I SENATE. FRIEDMAN- MULLIN
PATTERSON NO RIVAS SMITH NO.%
THREE TWO THANK YOU. NOW MAY I
HAVE A MOTION ON VOTE ONLY
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX PLEASE.
SECOND PROMOTION A SECOND
THIRTY DISCUSSION. LET'S
PROCEED TO VOTE WELL HI SENATE
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON NO
RIVAS SMITH YEAH. THREE TWO
THANK YOU OUR NEXT THE MOTION
WOULD BE FOR VOTE ONLY ISSUE
SIXTY SIX. THAT WERE MOTION A
SECOND DISCUSSION. LET'S
PROCEED TO VOTE WELL I SENATE.
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON.
RIVAS THAT YEAH. FOUR ZERO.
THANK YOU AND THE NEXT MOTION I
WOULD REQUEST TO BE VOTE ONLY
ISSUE THIRTY ONE FOR ALCATEL
LOW AND PRAIRIE. DISCUSSION.
CALL ROLL CALL PLEASE WELL HI
SENATE. FRIEDMAN WHAT PATTERSON.
RIVAS SMITH YEAH. FOUR ZERO
THANK YOU NEXT MOTION I WOULD
REQUEST A CERTAIN ISSUE THIRTY
ONE FOUR CANDLE STICK OCEANICA
AND STATEWIDE. THEIR SECOND.
THANK YOU. ROKOV A PLACE WHERE
I SENATE LIFE FRIEDMAN- MULLIN.
PATTERSON ACCORDING RIVAS SMITH
NO. THREE ONE. THANK YOU HELLO
OUR NEXT THE MOTION WOULD BE
FOR VOTE ONLY ISSUE. THIRTY TWO
FOUR- EL CAPITAN FORT ORD OLD
SACK. THE CARD CHAU AND DELTA
PROTECTION. WE HAVE A MOTION-
GOVERNMENTS ARE BENNETT AS
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
ROLL CALL PLEASE I DISCUSSION
ROLL CALL PLEASE WELL I. SENATE
FRIEDMAN HI SMALLER PATTERSON.
RIVAS SMITH YEAH. FOR THEIR.
THANK YOU AND OUR FINAL MOTION
WOULD BE ON THE OF VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR WOULD BE ISSUE THIRTY
TWO OSHANA. THERE MOTIONS.
THANK YOU LET'S HAVE A ROLL
CALL VOTE WELL. HI SENATE
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON.
RIVAS SMITH. EVERYONE THANK YOU
NOW MOVING TO THE ITEMS TO BE
HEARD THAT WERE- WE HAVE THE A
PUBLIC HEARING PREVIOUSLY ON.
ISSUE ONE THAT CARES ACT G. T.
F. S. AND SUPPORT TO SPRING
FINANCE LETTER STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE
THE SPRING FINANCE LETTER.
LET'S HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE WELL. I SENATE. FRIEDMAN
MULLIN PATTERSON. HI RIVAS
SMITH. FIVE ZERO THANK YOU IN
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE HIGHWAY
SAFETY PROGRAM THERE IS A-
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTER. THANK
YOU IS THERE DISCUSSION. I HAVE
A QUESTION. I'M SORRY I DO HAVE
A QUESTION I'M SORRY I WASN'T
HERE FOR THE PRESENTATION
HOPEFULLY THE FOLKS WHO CAN
ANSWER. BUT KELLY THAT'S PHILIP
THAT'S A QUESTION AND- THIS
WOULD PROBABLY BE FOR MISTER
CAC FROM CALTRANS PRIDE YEAH
RIGHT IT. I FEEL HE WOULD
PROVIDE A GREATER AGAINST
OPERATE GREAT GREAT THANK YOU
YET ATTY I KNOW THAT- METIN
MANY OF OUR HIGHWAY MAINTENANCE
PROGRAMS ARE- GOING TO BE
SAFETY ORIENTED AND JUST TRY
TO. FIND OUT WHAT'S THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN AND HM FOR
SAFETY PROGRAM AND A NORMAL
MAINTENANCE SAFETY PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MEMBER SO THIS- DAY
HM FOR SAFETY PROGRAM IS IT IS
A NEW PILOT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
BE UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF THE
OVERALL- HIGHWAY MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM SO WERE THE GOAL OF THE
HIGHWAY MAINTENANCE PROGRAM IS
REALLY TO. TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY AND THE CONDITION OF
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM AND
IT'S THE APARTMENTS IS. THIS
NEW PILOT PROGRAM WOULD REALLY
BE FOCUSED ON INSTALLING AND
MAINTAINING SPECIFIC SAFETY
COUNTERMEASURES- BE THERE ARE
THINGS LIKE- WELL PEDESTRIAN-
THE- SAKE ENHANCEMENTS WAR
SIGNS. WRONG WAY DRIVER
PREVENTIONS COUNTERMEASURES SO
THIS IS VERY SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON THESE- THESE TYPES
OF PROJECTS THAT WE WOULD
OTHERWISE DO. IN OUR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROGRAM AND BY DOING
THEM THROUGH THE MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM WERE ABLE TO GET THEM
DONE MORE QUICKLY BY FOCUSING
ON JUST THAT ELEMENT. AND
TAKING IT OUT OF A MUCH LARGER
PROJECT TAKES A LONGER TIME TO
UNDERSTAND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE WITHOUT AGAIN
THE- STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. AND IF
THERE'S NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
LET'S HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE. HI SENATE FRIEDMAN-
MULLIN PATTERSON. RIVAS SMITH
FIVE ZERO GREAT THANK YOU ISSUE
THREE OF THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HOLD OPEN- WHICH WE SHALL AS
THE- WITH THAT WE HAVE
CONCLUDED OUR BUSINESS EXCEPT
WE WILL HOLD THE OUT ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ANALYZE THE
SERGEANT TO CALL THE ABSENT
MANDERS MEMBERS AND- REQUEST
THEIR PRESENCE IN ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN FOURTH. WITH.
WAITING I THINK PEOPLE FOR MORE
THAN.
ONE NEARLY EVERYTHING
UNDER. FIVE CAN WE ARE. DO ADD
ONS- WE DON'T HAVE. ONE OF THE.
THE LEGISLATIVE IN THE- THREE.
FOR THE WOULD BE A ADAM- TO
ONLY A WERE THREE THROUGH EIGHT
TEN THROUGH 1-416-172-1220.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE
THIRTY THIRTY THREE THROUGH
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
THROUGH FORTY THREE FORTY SIX
OF. FORTY NINE FIFTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO THROUGH SIXTY
FOUR AND SIXTY SEVEN THROUGH
SEVENTY SEVEN. MORE PATTERSON.
RIVAS. SIX ZERO. L. THE NEXT TO
ADD ON WOULD BE FOR. BUT ONLY
IS USED TO THROUGH NINE. LET
ME. PAUSE HERE FOR A MOMENT.
MULLIN OUR OUR NEXT TO A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLIS HERE-
MANY PEOPLE IN THE MORNING SO-
LET'S SAYS STRIKE THE LAST VOTE
TO- THAT- MS RIVAS ADDED ON TO-
AND I WILL- AFTER THE- ROLE BE
OPENED ON ALL VOTE ONLY ISSUES
FOR A- MS REAVIS AND MISTER
MULLIN. FALLEN PRODUCT- ON THE-
ISSUE ONE THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO APPROVE THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER. WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS PLACE MULLIN.
RIVAS. SEVEN ZERO AND IF YOU TO
THE HIGHWAY SAFETY PROGRAMS
AGAIN THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MULLIN RIVAS. SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN
ZERO SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU I
THINK THAT COMPLETES ALL OF OUR
VOTING HAVE WE MISSED ANYBODY.
GETTING IN- THE SIGN THAT
EVERYONE IS VOTED THANK YOU
THIS IS PROBABLY THE FASTEST
MEETING THAT'S UP THREE HAS
EVER HAD- AND WE ARE ADJOURNED.